est ce que vous savez qui est le
champion du monde du 100 m ceux qui
n'ont micro oui c'est usain bolt
usain bolt est ce que vous voulez je lui
demande une chaîne qui est avec nous
merci à vous alors il voit plutôt la
cote va dire voilà et noir the most star
internacional in the world in the world
of words in you up in french in chile in
paris et thank you alors duchesne
pourquoi il ya parce que regarder
il y lance des trottinettes électriques
c'est ça une chaîne en trottinette et
elles sont magnifiques
magnifique alors ça vient d'arriver ça
ça va arriver à paris je peux vous dire
ça arrive non pas à paris demain
franchement je les ai essayé la sont
magnifiques alors justement eu chaîne
j'ai une petite question à poser est ce
que vous pouvez me faire 50 % parce que
je suis inquiet peu ric-rac en ce moment
juste pour moi formi formi 20%
c'est fait aussi où il s'est certes elle
s'est fait vrai maintenant elle son
humanité alors hussein je vais dire ça
sort demain franchement vous le dit elle
c'est écolo alors sur tout et on répète
en trottinette
il faut mettre il faut mettre le casque
en bref on est d'accord on y voit là
parce qu'il ya tous les jeunes qui nous
regardent franchement voilà il faut
mettre le casque mais elles sont
exceptionnelles couple stable au pied
sol parce qu'on met les pieds chaque
côté sont restés voulons c'est ça dans
le monde entier
c'était brest était servi alors et vous
avez vu leur temps au 100 m ces 180 au
100 m 23 80 pour c'est ma fiancée
ça vous fait rien c'est bien des lycées
malchance et wise as a lancé mario 23,81
sahara c'est nul c'est nul c'est pas mal
et franchement mais c'est faux alors une
chaîne
j'ai toujours eu un rêve c'est c'est de
te battre au 100 m mais je pense que 100
m normal j'ai pas envie de de j j -p
j'ai pas envie de ça j'ai pas envie de
te mettre mal devant le monde entier
donc est ce qu'on peut faire une course
de trottinettes tous les soirs alors
juste pour expliquer bien à trottinette
regarder sa trottinette vous avez elle
est magnifique parce qu'en fait vous
pouvez mettre vos deux pieds vous
démarrez vos deux pieds comme ça je les
ai essayé tout à l'heure c'est au top
franchement je suis chaîne pourquoi pas
relancer des trottinettes de crazannes
autres chats à cause de la circulation à
new york à londres par des passants
trottinette à la maison de tanja my way
est regardée franchement elle s voilà
elles sont elles sont assises ayant plus
de talent elles sont très très stylé du
chêne franchement on est comme des fous
de ce que vous soyez dans tpm p ce qu'on
vous aime
voilà où vous a suivi à chaque fois que
vous couriez j'étais comme un ouvrage
court et dans mon salon comme toi pour
te soutenir
je te le dis si c'est vrai je t'ai
toujours soutenu contre voilà contre
tous et coureurs est aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui c'est toi contre moi you
again semi baba contre une chaîne alors
on va prendre on va prendre une
trottinette
allez-y
quoi ah oui merci duchesne est ce que tu
sois capable de battre ah c'est bien
parce qu'il le prend très au sérieux
ouais c'est ça les inquiète pas enfin tu
qu and we go et fait une chute il est
beau gosse akon travail je sais mais je
vais pas lâcher à d'accord on fait quoi
à part merci
il va démarrer
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
ça va encore les films bigot encore une
victoire pour sert il
pas de série d'un jeu
franchement eh oui
il est fier
alors là
[Applaudissements]
whissell
oui semaine
[Applaudissements]
il est sympa une chaîne merci d'avoir
été avec nous franchement on te souhaite
beaucoup de chance pour la trottinette
on rappelle ces voix là c'est vraiment
en plus les prix sont hyper raisonnable
et je le répète c'est écologique et la
regarder le design des trottinettes elle
est folle et on est très heureux de
t'avoir eu avec nous parce que tu es
pour nous la plus grande star mondiale
je suis vraiment heureux de t'avoir
rencontré tu seras que tu as eu une
défaite lente à 10 et à dire merci
[Applaudissements]